un mouvement qui refuse de s'effacer des
militants qui continue de montrer leurs
muscles pour un neuvième samedi
consécutif les gilets jaunes se sont
fait voir et entendre et pas seulement à
paris et dans plusieurs villes
un même message de réformes
démocratiques de ras-le-bol contre les
riches et les élites et les gueux il va
falloir qu'il se sert encore la ceinture
y en a marre ça fait 45 ans voire 50 ans
que ça dure le jaune fluo a aussi fait
son apparition dans les rues de la
capitale britannique
certains y voient le signe d'une lutte
universelle tout le monde peut porter le
gilet jaune
tous les citoyens doivent se mélanger
aujourd'hui il faut comprendre que tous
les politiques sont corrompus qui soit
d'extrême gauche d'extrême droite qui un
message que plusieurs embouts lui livrer
dans le calme
d'autres de manière plus violents depuis
des semaines les affrontements entre
manifestants et policiers semblent
devenues inévitables comme les canons à
eau et des gaz lacrymogènes autour de
l'arc de triomphe
ou encore les arrestations musclées et
les blessés la colère ne semble pas
vouloir s'atténuer même si de vastes
consultations publiques sont organisées
pour mieux écouter les revendications
des consultations entachée par une
méfiance très forte envers les élus et
le président emmanuel macron moi je lui
ai dit oui mais à l'impossible pour
servir rien rien du tout il lira pas et
s'en moque
le scepticisme partagé par beaucoup de
manifestants eh bien les français c'est
un effort important et si on se mener là
c'est parce que maintenant ça peut plus
durer et on va aller jusqu'au bout ça
veut plus durer dialogue de sourds
estime éric drouin est il des voix les
plus écoutées et gilles et jean on a des
indications assez simple et on nous
répond que par la violence ou la ferme
était donc temps que rappaz un vrai
premier pas tarder à duke un bien
déterminée donc difficile d'entrevoir
une sortie de crise rapide ici lien et
du mont-bart en rade au canada paris